Welcome back everybody.
Our next guest's delicious food content on social media
will leave you wanting seconds, and drooling.
He has almost six million followers on Tik-Tok,
and over five million on YouTube.
And now his talents have landed him
on the New York times bestseller list,
with his latest book titled
"Joshua Weissmann, An Unapologetic Cookbook".
I spent the entire weekend reading it cover to cover,
it's amazing.
He's here, welcome Joshua Weissman.
(audience cheering)
How are you doing?
I have...
I know.
All of my favorite pages dog eared.
And what was funny is I was about to
write to the producers and be like,
"You know what recipe I wish we could make?
Is the Austin breakfast tacos."
And today we are making...
The tacos that you wanted.
The Austin breakfast tacos.
Right here, right here.
What are we doing first?
Okay, so very basic, no competition,
but we'll keep it very simple.
Eggs in the bowl, all right?
So it's super, super, super easy.
A lot of the time when people are making scrambled eggs,
you've all heard the stories, right?
The rules of scrambled eggs,
you can't salt them beforehand.
You can't whisk them too much
they'll become come too aerated.
But look, at the end of the day,
cooking is about making something that you enjoy, right?
So why would you be all stressed about it?
Just have fun with it.
So pans on, it's medium heat,
get a little bit of butter in there.
If I'm moving too fast by the way.
No, are you kidding?
Do you want to challenge me?
I do, go.
We can go full speed.
Yes Joshua, do it.
Butter's in the pan, we've got the eggs.
You can add a little bit of cream if you want,
or you can just leave them as eggs, whatever.
A little bit of salt.
Yes, I'm seasoning them beforehand.
Get that butter mixed around.
My eggs are our whisked and I'm adding them to the pan,
and just let them cook a little bit.
Essentially what you want is
you want to keep moving the pan.
Okay, so while these are cooking,
drop your temp all the way down the low.
Because it's going to keep going.
And then while that's stirring,
you're looking really good.
Really?
yeah.
I'm also getting a nice arm workout,
I'm not going to lie.
Let's double up that arm workout,
put your tortillas in the pan.
Can I borrow a tortilla Joshua?
You absolutely can borrow a tortilla,
how many would you like, one, two?
Two please.
Two, done.
In.
While our tortillas are heating,
you'll notice this pan is a lot hotter than this pan.
Alright, you're good there.
I would pull those guys off.
Okay, plate.
I can't remember if this was--
In fact, they feel so perfect,
and they're warm and delicious.
And like little warm babies, tuck, tuck.
Okay, well then first step is egg goes on.
Okay, so we have all of these accoutrement here.
Oh, I'm so excited.
I can't believe this is happening,
I've been thinking about this all weekend.
(audience laughing)
I'm not kidding, this has been my dream.
You, me and these Austin breakfast tacos.
(audience applauding)
See, what I love about these tacos
is how the bacon overhangs.
It almost yells that I'm here,
and this is going to be a great time.
Okay, so bacon's on, we have all of our...
you can add this in any order,
but this is the order that I would go in.
You already know, it's insane.
I did read your book front to back.
See, that's what happens.
Every little detail.
A little bit of jalapeno,
you can alternate them nice.
Make them look pretty.
How should I do my cilantro?
I have one quick tip.
So a lot of the time people will just take leaf by leaf,
but I think it looks a little more natural
if you take it from the stem here.
And you leave a little bit of stem,
and just prop it right on there.
It makes a little forest.
And there is flavor in the cilantro stem.
That's actually where the majority of the flavor is,
almost all the flavor is in the stem, not in the leaf.
Ah.
I'm sorry.
(audience applauding)
And then do we add a little cotija.
Oh yeah.
Just a little bit.
Now tell me about the salsa.
Sure, okay.
So this is a really special salsa.
I like to blend it a little finer sometimes,
but this is the salsa.
Think of all the Austin breakfast tacos
you've gotten, right?
And there's just this one salsa,
that's jalapeno and it's just jalapeno,
but for some reason it is so good.
What else is in here?
It is literally just jalapeno, garlic, oil, salt,
that is it nothing else.
And yet the flavor is undeniably higher
than any boxed, canned salsa you've ever had in your life.
You can smell it too, it's so good.
It's a really nice burst of (indistinct).
They can sink to that, I love it.
(audience applauding)
Oh my God.
It's so good.
What are you thinking,
what's going through your mind right now?
Having dreamt about this moment for days on end,
this is everything I was hoping it was going to be.
(audience applauding)
Yes.
That's what I'm talking about.
Wow.
And there is a spirit
of an extraordinary city in this dish,
that you are truly honoring.
That this whole globe, let alone country, needs to enjoy.
So thank you for teaching us this.
Thank you.
And bringing a piece of
Austin to our mouths and our hearts.
And I'm just so excited to meet you and work with you.
I'm just such a big fan of your book.
And I would love not to make this creepy,
but can we please do this again?
Yes, done.
Okay, cool.
Sweet.
Done.
Thank you, thank you Joshua Weissman,
Joshua's book, Joshua Weissman "An Unapologetic Cookbook"
is out now and available everywhere books are sold.
And it is so wonderful.
Get your copy if you don't have it already,
we'll be right back.
(mellow music)